philippe béchade rédacteur en chef de la
bourse au quotidien bonsoir philippe
béchade vous venez certainement d'écouté
l'analyse olivier delamarche c'est ce
que vous partagez vous le même
pessimisme en partie parce que c'est
vrai qu'on va connaître des temps un peu
difficile maintenant je vais pas me
lancer dans des spéculations sur la
durée de la crise parce que je pense que
c'est même à aujourd'hui la question
fondamentale
nous venons de changer de monde donc à
un monde vient de s'éteindre
il ya un film qui s'appelait le jour où
la planète star est à ce jour eh bien ce
sera pour les livres d'histoire pour les
livres d'économie qu'on écrira dans le
futur ce jour et le 16 mars 2020 donc
voilà que le jour où la terre s'arrêta
et où le système qu'elle qu'on l'a
connue a cessé d'exister
alors maintenant nous rentrons dans un
pays en transition et à dire que tous
les cadres que nous connaissons depuis
l'avènement de l'euro les règles
d'orthodoxie budgétaire tout ça vole en
éclats tout ça mais n'existe plus quand
on a eu quelques petits quelques petites
galères que comme la crise grecque par
exemple on nous a dit je n'ai pas
d'argent magie et que lorsque l'état
était survenue en 2010 on n'était pas
capable de
sortir d'un milliard pour éviter que le
problème grec contamine l'ensemble des
économies européennes et 20 milliards on
les avait pas à l'époque là aujourd'hui
on nous annonce 300 milliards pour
soutenir les entreprises françaises
c'est absolument nécessaires absolument
indispensable est justifié je vous
rassure si dans quinze jours on
s'aperçoit qu'à 300 milliards ne
suffisent pas il y en a 300 de plus il
ya vraiment aujourd'hui il n'y a plus
aucune limite dans la stratégie
d'endiguement de l'effondrement
économique
alors on va évidemment sauver les
entreprises
on va essayer de sauver la consommation
et aux états unis les rumeurs que nous
entendons déjà c'est que on devrait
peut-être recouvre recourir très
rapidement qu'on appelle d'hélicoptères
monnaie c'est à dire que la fed versera
directement sur le compte de chaque
citoyen américain
une somme se chiffrant en milliers de
dollars plusieurs milliers de dollars en
fonction de la longueur de la crise
autrement dit on va faire en 2020 ce
qu'on n'a pas su ferrand en 2008 alors
en 2008 on a redonné de l'argent aux
banques
et pour relancer l'économie il aurait
fallu effectivement donné de l'argent
aussi aux victimes de la crise
c'est-à-dire les citoyens ce qu'ils
produisent et la richesse il s'est
probablement ce qu'on va faire cette
fois ci alors je ne peux que m'en
féliciter sur le fond et le principe
par contre par contre il faut qu'on
réfléchisse à toutes les conséquences de
ce que je viens d'expliquer la silly
beyssade justement à la fin qui va payer
alors ça c'est une excellente question
parce que depuis 2008
en ce qui concerne l'argent banque
centrale distribués aux états aux
banques
personne n'a jamais payé les dettes ne
sont jamais rembourser elle sombre où
les ailes sont elles sont reportées
en europe on a une stratégie s'appelle
le tt zéro on en a créé 1 en 2015 arrivé
en 2018 les marchés poussent des cris de
douleur il a besoin de plus de l'utilité
on ne pouvait pas reprendre les 3000
milliards qu'on a des mises sur la table
en mars 2015
donc on a roulé ce tel terreau jusqu'en
2021 2022
et là on nous explique qu'on va ont
probablement en mettre un autre sur pied
encore plus massif et avec des taux
encore plus favorable puisqu'il serait
25 points de base en dessous du taux
actuel autrement dit on serait carrément
dans un refinancement à tout négatif
voilà donc c'est d'être là qui les
payent en vérité ça va être tout le
monde parce que quand on quand on va
sortir
mille cinq cent mille dards comme l'a
fait la fed plus 1800 milliards de
curieux mais celui 100 milliards c'est
qu'un chiffre provisoire ça plus haut ça
pourrait peut-être être 2 milliards dans
un mois personne ne remboursera sa part
être cela va affaiblir naturellement les
monnaies dans un premier temps on veut
en bus dès la dépression on veut pas
d'un scénario à la vénézuélienne ou à
l'argentine
c'est ça qu'on va essayer d'empêcher
dans un premier temps on va voir un choc
déflationniste
néanmoins puisque gens peuvent pas
consommer mais dans un deuxième temps
toute cette monnaie que l'on va sortir
elle fera pas remboursé à mon avis mais
c'est simplement que ça va déprécier la
monnaie en même temps qu'on déprécie la
monnaie sont là effectivement on assèche
la dette alors que quand la monnaie perd
de sa valeur on en bourse en monnaie de
singe et ça c'est un peu la solution
indolore
nestlé à dos lors qu'un certain temps
parce que dans un deuxième temps tout
cet argent clé va se transformer en
inflation donc en perte de pouvoir
d'achat de cette monnaie donc quelque
part la monnaie qu'on va créer mon plan
et 2000 milliards moi j'ai même entendu
parler de famine milliards de la part de
spécialistes des marchés obligataires
s'il pense que le grand risque
effectivement c'est l'éclatement de la
bulle des dettes corporate attentes des
entreprises et que pour empêcher cet
éclatement
il faudra probablement même être
probablement m 5000 milliards mais en
général on les mettra mais
ultérieurement ses 5000 milliards ce
s'évaporeront sous forme d'inflation et
on aura une inflation qui effectivement
correspondra à une sorte de deux chocs
en retour ou de phénomènes newtonien de
destruction de la monnaie merci philippe
béchade d'avoir été avec nous pour cette
analyse économique